ألقى البحارة مع خفر السواحل الليبي
حبل نجاة لقارب مليء
بالمهاجرين الذين ألقوا به في الماء
لا نريده يصرخ هذا الرجل
منذ بداية عام 2014 أكثر من 33000
شخص لقوا حتفهم وهم يحاولون عبور
البحر الأبيض المتوسط وفقًا لـ
المنظمة الدولية للهجرة
حتى الآن هؤلاء الأشخاص لا يريدون أن يتم
إنقاذهم لأن الإنقاذ يحتاج للعودة
إلى ليبيا في نهاية المطاف يقفز أحد البحارة من
فوق القارب ويسبح إلى
القارب ويربط الحبل على مضض حيث
يتسلق المهاجرون على متن سفينة خفر السواحل
[موسيقى]
الموت هو  من الأفضل أن تقول إحدى النساء أن
هناك القليل من الحب بين رجال الإنقاذ والإنقاذ ،
فأنت جميعًا تلعن ليبيا أيها الحيوانات
تصرخ للإبحار 28 شخصًا كانوا على
متن القارب المتهالك 22 من الصومال خمسة من
بنجلاديش واحدًا من اليمن فارًا من
فوضى الصراع والفقر وهذا هو
الجديد  الاضطراب
العالمي للقمة من الصومال يشرح سبب
محاولته القيام بهذا العبور الخطير
وسبب دخولي البحر هو
الوضع الذي هو غوي.  في
بلدنا حول الأشجار للعمل
، دفع الاتحاد الأوروبي
للحكومة الليبية في طرابلس أكثر من 250
مليون دولار لإيقاف جماهير العالم
الفقيرة المتعبة والمتجمعة التي تتوق
إلى التنفس بعيدًا عن الوصول إلى
شواطئها المباركة ، وتمول أموال الاتحاد الأوروبي
الساحل الليبي.  الحرس ويدعم بشكل غير مباشر
مراكز الاحتجاز لأولئك الذين تم
القبض عليهم وهم يحاولون عبور البحر الأبيض المتوسط
أوروبا ، ما يقرب من 6000 شخص عالقون في
راكز مثل مركز الاعتقال Tariqa Sitka في تريبلي في نه
ية المطاف قد يت
إعادتهم إلى بلدانهم الأصلية أو ما
بقى منهم قد
نتقدت منظمات حقوق ال
نسان  الظروف في مراكز الاحتجاز هذه ،
لكن الاتحاد الأوروبي الذي تمزقه الخلافات بين
الدول الأعضاء لم يغير سياسته
فيما يتعلق بالمهاجرين في ليبيا
على الرغم من أوجه القصور الصارخة ،
فقد يغادر المهاجرون ليبيا يومًا ما ، لكن
الصدمة التي عانوا منها في رحلتهم
ستبقى خاصة مع العديد من
النساء.  ما تبقى من حياتهم
ثمانية عشر عاما التبرع من
تقول إريتريا إن المُتجِرين اعتدوا عليها جنسياً
وضربونا بحزام تتذكره
أكثر مما اغتصبونا ثم
أطعمونا واغتصبونا وهي الآن حامل قريباً
لتلد في مركز احتجاز مع
القليل من الرعاية الطبية
محظوظة أيضًا تبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا.  هي من الصومال
تقول إن المهربين اغتصبوها مرارًا
وتكرارًا ، ثم ولدت
الحمد لله الذي باركني بهذا الطفل
لا أستطيع التخلص منه ، الطفل جزء
من جسدي ، لكن أرجوكم تتوسل لي
من هنا من بين ثماني نساء يعملن لحسابهن الخاص
قال المصور غبريال شيام ، الذي تمت مقابلته في
هذا المركز ، إن سبعة تعرضوا للاغتصاب
بالقرب من ضواحي طرابلس ، وكانت
الحرب بين الفصائل الليبية
المتنافسة على الغرب حريصة على المساعدة في
إسقاط نظام معمر القذافي
ولكن منذ ذلك الحين أدارت ظهرها
لليبيا البلاد.  أصبحت ساحة
للمنافسات المحلية والإقليمية ،
والخوف الجنوني الذي يتحمله العالم
طالما بقي الجنون هنا ، ثم
لم نكن لـ CNN
[موسيقى]